vous ne rêvez pas cet agriculteur film
sa parcelle pendant une quinzaine de
secondes luc laurin utilise en fait une
application qui l'a créé crop analyseur
le téléphone prend
une photo toutes les secondes ce qui
permet de faire une analyse de chaque
image chaque photo
pour déterminer la couverture foliaire
c'est à dire le couvert végétal
l'application indique ici 3% de feuilles
de colza logique il a été semé il ya une
dizaine de jours seulement en répétant
l'opération régulièrement l'agriculteur
va ainsi pouvoir suivre de près le
développement de ces cultures réagir
plus vite en cas de maladie ou utiliser
plus ou moins de produits
phytosanitaires selon les prévisions de
rendement c'est un gain de précision
parce que
comment je pourrais vous dire ici je
l'amène par exemple dans la parcelle dix
agriculteurs jordi de regarder le colza
il ya un qui va me dire il est beau lot
de pabos votre moyen l'autre commence
comme ci comme ça comme ça le téléphone
il va parler pareil pour tout le monde
cette application est relié à un site
internet où sont archivés comparer les
photos et les données pour créer cet
outil numérique l'udc a planché pendant
huit ans aidé par sa femme est un
développeur web il a fallu créer une
base de données parce que dans crampes
analyse a en fait y'a un algorithme
mathématique et pour arriver à calais la
formule mathématique au plus juste en
fait il a fallu prendre des photos pour
chaque culture et c'est à peu près 3000
photos par culture en effet il n'ya pas
que le colza cinq autres cultures sont
aussi concernés comme la betterave à
peine lancé l'application intéresse
d'ailleurs déjà des agro industriels du
secteur avec qui des premiers tests ont
été réalisés